I'm going to be going apologies for
absence I've got apologies from George
why no nothing there any others number
was attending obviously there are none
minutes to the meeting there was a 26 to
to lie are you happy that I signed them
as a true record
thank you receive declarations of
interest if any anything turns up during
the meeting please let me know
make sure it's militating there are no
matters referred from other committees
so we go straight to the quarter one
financial management and performance and
I don't know if you want to speak to
this at all young man just a small
apology first in case anyone's got any
specific questions of detail
unfortunately through a variety of
circumstances who have not solutionist
officer support tonight but I'll take
any detail questions of detail and
provide answers for you subsequently
have required but the the report shows a
positive variance overall in the first
quarter we should bear in mind that it's
combination of some areas in surplus and
some in deficit as we know homelessness
is a increasing stress on the council's
finances it's nothing to do with factors
that were able to control all the
reasons behind it we
control however we can do something
about it and were actively doing
something about it as we've discussed
and forwarded in a variety of their
previous meetings the the various
portfolio reports are printed there from
6:45 onwards and I think the the real
thing that we can take from the report
is we can see that all the various
headings of all being closely monitored
if something isn't exactly on track but
the positive or negative but analyzing
those reasons and keeping a close eye
this is only the first quarter and
overall we have got a surplus so we
can't be satisfied but we always strive
to be as accurate as we can with our
objections and we continue to work hard
on those across all the areas I say the
homelessness figures we have they're
around a 1.1 it's if it is very so he
doesn't have one so I'm looking at one
page
yes it's under three point four it's
very worrying that increases well you
know in a quarter you know there's an
exponential business it's very worrying
in daily but I think something you know
you really I mean we're obviously doing
the right thing with creating the
temporary accommodation that we have
focusing Francisco to lodge and 22 South
stroke using the time'll program it's
exactly the right decision to learning
but I think it is judging for the record
that with this increase if we haven't
taken the action that we have then we
are taking to provide accommodation
within the district then we would be
effectively forcing families out of
district we've been moving them away
from their families friends under the
support networks the children away from
their schools and of course it wouldn't
lean you know increase the costs of this
council as well right so you know I
think that's something to take into
account but I think it's something that
it needs to be very closely monitored
and take forward as you say the other
things are pretty much sort of you know
you're always going to get ups and downs
this is honking the first quarter so
clearly you know we don't quite know
where we're going to be by the end of
the year it is positive that we've got a
surplus if you like even though we've
had those various pressures come to us
but other than that I think you're
absolutely right you know it's think we
have the mechanisms and the checks and
balances in place to make sure that you
know if there is something that's out of
kilter we will try and tackle it soon as
we have some begin and that's the right
way to go anybody else like yes please
sure Thank You chairman as long might
continue
you know we carry on like this following
on from the last exam when I actually
suggested we had free pumpkin December
our Saturday mornings I would love to
put that forward again and I would like
to propose that we have free parking on
Saturday mornings over second 9:16 and
23rd of December just take a look okay
thank you
anybody wanted to speak to that or all
members are pretty weak ranking what I
think we noted please
forward they show these judges follow
after that could we obviously make sure
that appropriate publicity is given to
that because it's not it's not an easy
thing to do in the current climate
current financial climate it is it is
our present to the to the people of the
district and it's been owned by are hard
workers counselors making sure the
budget is is in a position to to take
the yeah hmm yeah sorry my packet there
just to update the first residence we're
moving into Francisco Suraj and South
Street this month so it's good news and
thanks to the reason Moss and her team
are working very hard on that South
Stream I said a few weeks ago members of
two around the South Street quite
impressed it's the first mental public
service oh that's very impressive very
impressive okay but any other points yes
minute Simon with this is only the first
quarter fingers what's your feeling in
the next quarter Thank You Phil back to
work and so on failings
I I think we'll have a small surplus
again in the net in the next quarter we
know that there isn't some stuff in
savings still to be not to be taken
however over the course the ER I think
it might be hard for long time on target
hopefully in the positive side so as far
as the recommendations are being
concerned the three recommendations
there are they were agreed I'm very
relieved
Thank You acrostic are packaged in
plastic are those cotton yes please
thank you but or now we're going into
private session so I move that we do
that now